[Música]
qué genial sería si la motivación fuera
contagiosa
imaginemos si la motivación fuera
solo tendríamos que ir a buscar una
fuente inspiradora ponernos al lado y
llenarnos de esta energía que nos
alcanzaría para vivir la vida que
querramos y para tomar los riesgos que
quisiéramos tener
si la motivación fuera contagiosa
organizaremos al día despertando los
bien temprano y poniendo a martin luther
king con su discurso famoso
recordándonos de que nosotros también
tenemos un sueño si la motivación fuera
contagiosa camino al trabajo veríamos
los carteles en el metro en la autopista
recordando dos frases famosas de
célebres escritores
pensando que si no dejes para mañana lo
que puedas hacer hoy y lleno de energía
estaríamos transformando nuestra nuestro
día laboral generando muchísimo valor y
a la vuelta en casa pondremos a los
chicos a dormir contando las historias
de grandes héroes que tomaron riesgos
con eso nos iríamos a dormir tranquilos
sabiendo que esos chicos ya están
preparados para un mundo buenísimo
pero no
la motivación no es contagiosa
la motivación que obtenemos de otro es
prestada
la motivación de escuchar a alguien
contarnos su historia no es lo
suficientemente poderosa para
transformar la nuestra
y vamos buscando historias inspiradoras
pero volvemos a la vida real
donde nuestra nuestra realidad tiene
miedos tiene frustraciones tiene
inseguridades y vivimos en esta
dicotomía
si la motivación fuera contagiosa ya nos
habríamos dado cuenta
viviríamos en un miedo en un mundo súper
motivado ya sería como muy obvio no sé
si les pasa pero vamos a leemos algo
vamos a un cine la del cine vamos a un
cine vemos una película que nos
transforma salimos llenos de energía de
esta de esta película decididos a volver
a casa y abrazar a nuestra familia y
empezar de nuevo
pero camino al coche no nos acordamos
donde hemos aparcado
y decimos [ __ ] porque estaba aquí es
que yo lo dejé aquí y me lo han robado
se lo ha llevado en la grúa y esa
conversación inspiradora de la película
no ha llegado ni siquiera a pasar dos
tres manzanas hacia él hacia el parque
es que eso no es sólo algo que nos
ocurre a nosotros las personas pensemos
en las organizaciones también
en las organizaciones muchos creemos que
poniendo carteles con misión visión
valores va a alcanzar para que la gente
trabaje juntos para que haya
colaboración que haya innovación que
haya un foco en el cliente que haya una
mentalidad digital y que todos
trabajemos por el bien de nuestros
pacientes nuestros clientes
pero lamentablemente no es así no es así
hoy más del 90% de las personas no
quieren ir a trabajar gente esta
empleada resiste el ir a trabajar no
disfruta de ir a trabajar
yo creo que
en realidad está en esta dicotomía tiene
un origen esto viene
de que nos contaron más la historia no
sé si algunos conocerán la pirámide de
la famosa pirámide de maslow donde nos
dijeron que era lo importante como
humanos y en esta receta y endesa fiable
quedaba muy claro que primero es el agua
y la comida y ahí todo muy bien y luego
la seguridad y luego la familia y el
grupo social pero arriba como como el
diamante de esta pirámide estaba la
autorrealización
y aquí nos lo dejaron ahí como colgando
pero con el paso de los años empezamos a
creer que esta autorrealización tenía
que ver conmigo y el foco era nuestro
ombligo
esta cosa de crecer tenía que ver con
ser más cuidarme más crecer más ser más
creativo auto realizarme y ahí creo que
se nos arruinó un poco la foto ahí
empezamos a mirarnos a nosotros en vez
de mirar para afuera
yo tengo una forma de mirar esto que
quizás les sirva yo veo que
a donde pongo el foco esto es lo que
define el origen de mi motivación y mi
capacidad para tomar riesgos imagínense
un continuo
con dos extremos en un extremo
está el que me valoren
tiene valor en que me vaya bien en mi
carrera que me den más son bonos de fin
de año que que me promuevan que me den
otro trabajo que me vaya bien comprar
una casa más grande y tener likes en el
facebook para ver cuánta gente me sigue
todo esto
en el otro extremo
es el usar mi talento y mi tiempo para
generar valor no para buscar ser
valorado sino ser el que genera valor y
valor para un cliente para un vecino
valor para un paciente para un familiar
para cualquiera esto no hablo de
solamente hacer cosas de voluntariado
hablo de que lo que hacemos en el día a
día sea generar valor y es ahí
casualmente donde está la mayor fuente
de motivación y la mayor capacidad para
tomar riesgos si volvemos los grandes
líderes del mundo
no estamos muy preocupados mandela por
lo que le iba a pasar a él el foco
estaba en qué valor voy a generar y por
eso lo tenemos a él como alguien que
tomo grandes riesgos pero desde este
lugar yo vivo una vida muy chiquita vive
una vida protegiendo me para que nada me
pase nos hemos educado a nosotros mismos
para cuidarnos así como para no no
pasarla mal y sobrevivir la vida pero si
estamos hablando de tomar riesgos si
estamos hablando de hacer una diferencia
está del otro lado
y tengo que dejar esto para poder
focalizar en algo que me motive
para que esto tenga sentido y esta no
sea una charla motivacional quiero que
ustedes ahora piensen en una situación
actual personal o profesional donde no
se animan a tomar un riesgo
si son humanos tienen más de una
cualquiera quiero que la agarren y digan
ok en la escala esta que estamos
hablando de la que estamos hablando en
mi escala de valor donde están ustedes
en esa situación
están tratando de ser gustado de ser
valorados por un entorno externo les da
miedo perder
están más comprometidos con el valor que
van a generar en esta situación
y en esto obviamente es una decisión no
somos víctimas de la situación creemos
que sí pero no somos víctimas
elegimos a donde queremos estar en esta
dimensión de valor individualmente y
como organizaciones es exactamente igual
quiero que piensen ahora en qué acción
podrían tomar ustedes y acción con esto
me refiero algo muy concreto algo que
van a tomar en aproximadamente seis
minutos cuando tengamos el break una
acción que nos va a mover desde este
extremo hacia ese completamente no pero
en la dirección que quieren ir y una
acción que tenga formato de whatsapp que
tenga formato de mensaje de texto de una
llamada telefónica de una conversación
y que los ponga ustedes en el lugar del
conductor tomando riesgos en algo que
ustedes saben el por qué lo van a hacer
porque tienen un foco en esta generación
de valor hacia afuera no el cuidarse
hacia adentro ahora no se puede tener
las dos cosas
y aquí la clave está en la palabra
decisión porque van a tener que decidir
todos tenemos que decidir que queremos
vivir acá o vivir acá y obviamente hay
mucho socialmente que nos atrae a que
nos den más likes en nuestro facebook y
cuántos seguidores cuánta gente lee mi
blog
y yo mismo voy me engancho con eso dijo
no pero eran 30 mil euros 27 mil ya no
me quieren
donde el foco no era ese el foco es para
que estoy escribiendo que mundo quiero
dejar después de mi paso por el que
tenga mejor sentido que esté mejor que
lo que yo encontré cuando cuando llegue
y la palabra decisión es clave en esto
porque decidir la terminación civil
viene del latín títere y que es el sitio
de otras palabras muy conocidas como
herbicida suicida
homicida la terminación sirio implica
matar
qué es lo que mató yo cuando decido
entre esta escala de valores tengo que
matar la necesidad de que de que me
quieran de que me valoren esto va a
venir pero no lo pudiera buscar lo que
tengo que ir a buscar es algo que me
motive para tomar los riesgos que tengo
que tomar tengo que buscar algo donde mi
talento y mi tiempo estén usados para un
buen propósito y solo ahí es donde voy a
encontrar el origen de la de la decisión
lo bueno de esto es que está genial que
la motivación no sea contagiosa
es genial porque depende de nosotros no
necesitamos absolutamente nada más para
que la motivación funcione en nosotros
y eso es algo que nosotros lo tenemos
y lo podemos usar en cada momento en
cada día y hasta el resto de nuestras
vidas muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]